So, let's try this. I would put all of this functionality in a method, give me
a minute to arrange that and then I'll show you. As promised, here is my method.
This method keeps reading an integer until it finds
one that is within the desired range and then it
returns it. The exact code isn't really important right
now. You can have a look at it in the
code distribution, if you want to. And, out here,
I'm calling it. But, there's a problem. When I compile
it, I get an error message. And, that error
message, right now, must truly appear like gibberish to you.
It talks about non-static methods and static methods.
So let me explain what's happening and why the
compiler is unhappy. Normally, we call a method on
an object and I didn't do that here because
I figured, well I'm in elevator demo. So I
should be able to call any elevator demo method
as well. But the trouble is I'm calling from
main. So there are no elevator demo objects and
the compiler complains. So going back here, that is
the crux of the problem. ReadBetween is not called
on an object And there really isn't a great
object to call it on. it would have been nice
to call it on the scanner, but like I
already said, we can't do that. Whenever you're in this
kind of situation where you have a method that
can't really be called in an object, then you make
a static method. The static method is a method that's not called in any
object. So, one remedy is, simply, to go back into elevator
demo. And, declare the helper method static. Like this. Now, all
will be well. And the syntax error is gone. So to answer our original question,
it is perfectly legitimate to put read between
intra ElevatorDemo as a static method but maybe
it's not optimal. Because what if I want
to use that perfectly nifty method in another
class? So really, read between is a method that seems it would be useful in any
situation that you want to read a value from
some range. So we, we might really want to put
this somewhere else, and the dos that I'm going
to put it on I'll call IO Helper. I've
prepared that class for you, let me show you.
Here is the IO Helper class. Here is the
read between method. And again, that is a static
method because I'm not going to actually make any
objects off the IO Helper class. I just want
it to be the home for this method. That means
when I call the method, I have to specify
the name of the class like this. Here you
see the name of the class, IOHelper, the name
of the method. Static methods are not incredibly common because,
like I said,most of the time, an actual object
is responsible for carrying out a method, but they do
happen. In fact, you've seen a few of them. In
lesson four, you saw a good number of static methods
in the math class. Again, the syntax is the name
of the class, a period, and then the name of
the method. And once again there is no object of
the math class. We simply call the square root method
directly on the class. Now, you may wonder, why
did we have to use a static method? Why
couldn't we just call the method on the number
2? Well, that's what it's like in Java. In
Java, numbers are not objects so you can never
call a method on an object. A call such
as 2. square root might be more logical, but
it's an error. So to summarize the static method.
Belongs to a class. It's not called in an object and they're not actually all
that common. Why do you call them
static methods? There's no good reason actually. That's
a holdover from another much more ancient
programming language. There's nothing particularly static about them.
In addition to static methods, there are static
variables. Let's have a look at them next.